hey guys it's Monday and unfortunately
I'm damn but fortunately I'll be giving
away a bunch of free codes for games so
stay tuned for that and a whole bunch of
news first up support for 4k media
playback has been added to the ps4 pro
well you'll never be able to watch 4k
blu-rays on your ps4 Pro due to hardware
limitations today's update to the media
player adds support for 4k MP forge once
the update is installed you'll be able
to play back the files by a USB or home
server
unfortunately drubbs formatted as
external ps4 storage are incompatible
with the media player for those of you
with a PlayStation VR and nothing to do
with it after finishing ghostbusters VR
for the millionth time you'll now be
able to watch 4k VR videos through the
media player as well though the PS VR
headset will still only output at 1920
by 1080 speaking of PlayStation VR
here's me getting spooked playing here
they lie and here's a code so you too
can get wicked spooked I hope you like
sales charts because I'm about to recite
some sweet sales numbers for you
Mass Effect Andromeda has dethroned
Ubisoft's latest collectathon Ghost
Recon wildlands in the UK Andromeda is
number one on the physical sales charts
in front of the aforementioned Ghost
Recon wildlands at two Lego worlds at
three and horizon zero dawn taking the
fourth position what's that you want an
or a machine trapper Pack DLC code well
here you go
closing out the top five UK sales for
this week is the game that just keeps
going Grand Theft Auto 5 if you want to
know what the other five are the hold is
in there you can check out the rest of
the figures in our story on GameSpot
finally destiny 2 has been officially
announced confirming what we had long
suspected the Wizards from the moon at
Bungie have announced destiny sequel as
destiny - the pick you're looking at
right now was tweeted by the series
official Twitter account it appears to
show Earth's last city smouldering after
some sort of attack and the traveler
looks yes unfortunately no more details
have been shared as yet side note if the
speaker doesn't turn out to be super
evil I am going to be disappointed
please take note Bungie the tweet comes
after photos of posters started
appearing online last week showing a
release date of September 8th
though this is still unconfirmed we'll
be bringing you all the destiny 2 news
as it happens so be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss a thing
that's it for today i have set false
expectations for when I host news now by
giving away free games head to GameSpot
to check out reboot our show about
gaming and culture and
here's a code for alienation I guess
I'll see you guys later